When my plane landed here, the
flight attendant welcomed everyone
to West Yellowstone, Montana,
and added: "don't feed the bears".
There's a lot of reminders
not to do that.
The whole of Yellowstone Park,
which starts just a couple hundred
metres that way, is bear country.
And hikers and campers heading
from this town into the wilderness
will bring food with them.
If the wind's in the right direction, then
a bear can smell that food miles away.
Which isn't great for the humans,
who do not want a hungry grizzly bear
that weighs a third of a ton rummaging
through and destroying their campsite.
But it's not great for the bears either.
Bears are relatively smart creatures,
and if one of them makes
the connection between humans...
and easily available food,
it might start seeking out
campsites and homes,
it might get aggressive.
And in that case, it might
have to be... euthanized, killed.
Not just for human safety, but because
it might pass that behaviour
along to its cubs,
and along to their cubs,
and suddenly,
the wilderness isn't so wild anymore.
So that's problem number one.
There are rules for people going into
the park, and one of them involves
keeping all your food in bear resistant
containers, a bit like these trash cans.
So problem number two.
How do you certify that a container
is actually bear resistant?
Here at the Grizzly and Wolf
Discovery Center, they're trying to
solve both those problems in one go.
Rather than euthanizing a bear that's a
bit too interested in pick-a-nick baskets,
it can get moved here, just outside
the park, where it might get a new job:
testing containers.
- On average, our bears test around
60 products per season, which runs
from April 1st to October 1st.
Without a doubt, coolers are number one.
30 to 40 coolers.
Seems like everybody wants to make
a bear resistant cooler these days.
So then we have the trash cans,
something you'd roll out
to the end of your driveway.
Some metal products even get tested here.
We want those products to pass the test so
that out in the field a bear doesn't get
that food reward and moves on, continues
back into the woods where they belong.
Fish is their number one favorite.
Peanut butter and honey is a close second.
And then we either put dried
dog kibble or dog treats inside.
Quite often we put a dummy container in,
To give those bears a food reward
every once in a while.
If they were to not be able to get into
a product, 20 products in a row.
Why, perhaps, would they try
to get in that 21st time?
So let them remember that there's a
lot of goodies inside, and they need to
put that effort into trying to get in.
- Definitely no bears
in here right now?
- No bears.
Lots of double checks, security,
radio calls.
- So obviously, I asked to put a camera
inside one of the
dummy trash cans,
one of the trash cans that the bears
would definitely get into.
I didn't think the team here would
let me, but they said yes immediately.
And in hindsight,
of course they said yes.
The bears are literally being given a
load of plastic and metal to rip apart
in the hope of reaching the food inside.
A camera in a protective case is not going to make any difference to them.
They're not going to eat it.
They're smart enough not to.
- The bear's favorite method, at least
with the trash can, we find,
is the "CPR method", pushing
up and down with their paws,
and a lot of times they
separate the lid from the body.
With coolers, they're gonna use their
teeth to tear the plastic apart.
And then the styrofoam,
and then the next layer, and then
it's a clean-up on aisle four.
- My big concern here was animal welfare.
There is a centuries-long history of bears
being mistreated for entertainment,
and I do not want to be part of that.
This place has to survive as a non-profit,
and as a tourist attraction,
but that can't mean putting
the bears' welfare at risk.
Fortunately, the team here
are very clear that they don't
want that to happen either.
- We would never want to put
the bears at risk, for sure.
These are all rescued bears
that came from the wild.
We're very, very hands off.
We don't call out to the bears.
We don't talk to the bears.
We want them to remain
as wild as possible.
We also ask the public to
not call out to the bears.
The bear habitat is about an acre in size.
We do have two ponds, a waterfall,
and lots of trees and rocks and logs.
We stock the pond with
fish all summer long.
The food that's hidden out in the bear
habitat in front of the public is just
an enrichment to keep them active.
It's a snack.
Let them do their natural behaviors
like they would in the wild.
- It turns out that it's really
difficult to make a container that
humans will want to use, and can use,
but that bears can't get into.
Yesterday, I tried to use one of those
bear resistant trash cans, and it
had been jammed shut by someone that
apparently couldn't figure it out,
and just shoved their
garbage in the latch.
Because, there's an old quote, allegedly
from some park ranger in the 1980s,
I couldn't find the original source,
that says, there's a considerable
overlap between the brainpower of
the most intelligent bears, and
the least intelligent tourists.
- 60 minutes of contact time.
Quarter inch hole or larger is a fail.
We always say "bear resistant"
because we feel that if you give a
bear an unlimited amount of time,
they'll get in most everything.
Not "bear proof", no guarantees.
Those bears are gonna come around and try
to get that easy meal each and every time.
We're trying to educate the visitors to
not make the same mistakes
that got most of our bears here
in the first place.
More and more bears are staying
out of trouble in the wild.
- Where's it gone?
Oh yeah, no, that's a bear with a GoPro.
That is a bear with a GoPro.
Sadly, definitely not recording anymore.
Oh, don't put it in the water.
Don't... do not put the GoPro
in the water, bear. That's...
And it's gone.
That's... not ideal.